another
Dave strike and an open receiver to the
chase another touchdown
[Applause]
[Music]
sets up fliers to
touchdown
- on that south the three on this side
the key goes beyond them next protection
he's going to live on deep he's got a
man up there Justin Jefferson touchdown
LSU a 40-yard strike from Baroda
Jefferson's receiver look
[Applause]
the outside except the play action for
burrow going up top toward the end John
Jefferson is yeah that's another catch I
that safety down give this receiver a
chance and they have to add Justin
Jefferson with the late hands
[Applause]
Dutch Jefferson
[Applause]
watch Joe burrow work his way navigate
his way and throw it right in the face
of another blitzing safety Chris Brown
and then there's Justin Jefferson doing
what he does after the kick
the Tigers leading rusher touchdown
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a muscle play from wood
what's that
touchdown Paris Marshall I thought they
might go to the corner but it got it
easier throw they went slots on the
slant and he wasn't sure he wanted to
put his family through that
and a deep strife animal could receive
her
gelareh chase another touchdown she's
running a deep Hudson the safety on his
side Richardson was peeking up across
the room and got here the deep safety
you have to be the deep and ended up
transferring to Nebraska I had a chance
to visit with him today before the game
over at the Grove
borrow throws Tamar chase wide open
McKinney's gonna leave the pocket
he's not gonna panic his eyes are
downfield and he sees Jabbar chase get
behind the defense takes it every time
pickup of a cane girl
[Applause]
[Music]
you gotta put this thing in a hammerlock
just before the half
what up at your boy Adam left go do you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report